- [Toby] Thank you for making the trip
all the way out to Mandalay Bay.
I know this is one of the harder venues
to kind of get people into.
So I appreciate you making the trip.
Today we're gonna talk about
what's on the screen here,
maximizing EC2 performance.
So this is a code talk
and this is a little bit
of a different format
than what I,
I've only given one other code talk
and I was at a Toronto summit,
and I was on ground level,
so I'm not used to being
up here on the stage.
And I was hoping to make
this a little more dynamic,
but now given that we're up here
and not able to kind of mingle it,
maybe it's gonna be a little bit weird,
but I have stickers.
So if I was, you're gonna be,
if you were answering questions
or we were getting some engagement,
I was gonna give out stickers.
I can't really hold 'em a hostage.
So if you do want a sticker,
please afterwards come and get,
talk to me and I'll be
happy to give you one.
But yeah, my name's Toby Buckley.
I am a specialist solutions
architect on EC2 team.
I focus on EC2 performance
and helping customers
get the most out of EC2.
I'm joined by Geoff.
- [Geoff] Hi, I'm Geoff,
Geoff Blake, I'm principal
engineer for Annapurna Labs
at AWS, where I work on
optimizing performance
for Graviton instances
all the way from user software,
which we'll talk about today,
all the way down into the hardware,
which we'll also touch on.
- [Toby] Geoff's super smart guy.
So yeah, I think we
should have an interesting
jam-packed session for you today.
This is what we're gonna talk about
really just kind of talking
about performance engineering
from a high level perspective.
So not necessarily getting,
I know we got one HFT
person in the audience.
I'm not gonna necessarily get into
the high frequency trading,
like low level performance stuff.
This is more of a high level stuff,
although some of the tools
we have may bring to bear
some good signals for you
to kind of, APerf being that tool.
So we'll introduce Aperf.
If you're not familiar with that,
it's a great tool
for understanding the
performance of your system.
And then we've got a couple of examples.
We've got a Groovy demo.
Anybody, any Groovy users out here,
any Java Groovy users.
Okay, so one, it's great,
but I'm not a Groovy expert either,
but kind of put this demo together
really to try to be not so contrived
that it seems silly for those
that are in the audience,
but one that is more mimics
maybe a natural organic growth
of an application at a company.
It starts off pretty innocent
and then it starts getting big
and then it gets slow
and now you need to understand why, right?
So something more like that.
We also have one on MongoDB,
and how you can get more
performance outta MongoDB,
and how the tools can surface the signals
so that you can understand why.
And then like any good talk
we're gonna send you off
with a call to action.
I think that's it.
I'm gonna turn it over to Geoff,
what just level setting here.
I'm gonna run some of the slides.
He's gonna do the coding,
as I said before,
we don't have a whole lot of code
for you to follow through with.
So there's none of this stuff
is in a repo necessarily,
but I'd be happy to
connect with you offline
and we could maybe offer
up whatever we can.
We could potentially get
some of this in a repo
if that's of interest to people.
But again, hit me up afterwards,
outside or after the talk
and we'll talk about
what logistics look like
moving forward.
So with that, I'll hand it off to Geoff.
- [Geoff] Okay, so we're gonna introduce
performance engineering
for those that may not do
this day in and day out
like myself and some of my team,
but I guess a show of hands,
who does performance engineering
as their primary role?
Okay, one, so you might
know some of this already,
but for the rest of you
we're gonna give a quick primer
on performance engineering.
So when we go down to the code
and try to figure out what we're gonna try
to take advantage of to
make things go faster,
you have a little bit
of a base to rely on.
So performance engineering very simply
is just finding
opportunity in your system,
whether that's for efficiency
gains, price efficiency
or performance efficiency,
which I like the most.
But price performance engineering
is also something we wanna
find opportunities for.
And while that sounds simple,
it has some big challenges.
One of them is abstractions
that you rely on
to build your software.
Everyone uses things like sockets
and web frameworks to
build their software.
So they just concentrate
on their business logic.
When looking for
opportunities for performance,
those things can leak where
you have to start looking
underneath your abstractions
that you rely on
to build your logic,
but now they're not
performing the way you want.
You have to go and look
underneath the covers.
So case in point, we were
helping a customer optimize
some code that they were trying to get
performant on Graviton,
I'm a Graviton engineer
so I'm gonna talk a lot about Graviton,
is they had this abstraction
they built their software on
and we had to actually
go into the abstraction
they had no knowledge of
and actually show them
that their optimization
wasn't in their code.
It was in this abstraction
that we had to go
and do some away team
programming to make faster.
And again, abstractions
leak, everything has a cost.
Now you have to start thinking
about what you've built,
what you're building on
and what those costs
are to try to understand
how you can find more opportunities
such as you don't just have
a VM that's all by itself.
It may have different storage,
different networking characteristics
and you have to know what those costs are,
not just in price
but also what performance it can get
or what performance you're
not getting from that.
Another part with performance engineering
is bottlenecks may hide others.
You can have a bottleneck
that you're trying to remove
to get your performance up
and then when you finally fix it,
you find you've uncovered a worse problem
that was just hiding behind it.
We had something like this where we fixed
the performance of a network application
and we uncovered a synchronization problem
that actually made the
performance worse by 15x.
And we had to go underneath again.
We had to dig into the abstractions
we were relying on
to find that second bottleneck
before we actually got the
performance we expected.
So these are things that
can finally lead to just,
I've already talked about a
lot of things that can happen.
This is a search space explosion.
So lots of things to think about.
It's a very rich environment
to go and learn things.
Be curious about what
it is you're building
and what you can do to make things faster.
'Cause you start understanding
the different layers
and the different costs of
everything you're working with.
But let's talk about how we're going
to actually just do
performance engineering.
Ideally the model is you define
what you're going to measure,
you're gonna measure it,
we're gonna understand
it, we're gonna tune it,
we're gonna get some performance,
we're gonna get some more efficiency
and we're gonna go around
this loop a few times
and finally come out the other side
and say, yay, we're done.
And performance engineering,
for those who are
wondering, it's never done.
It's just something you stop.
You say my return on
investment's good enough,
I'm gonna stop.
I'm not gonna look for
that extra half percent
or extra 10th of a percent.
It's not worth it.
But you may find that again,
the reality is gonna
be a little different.
With performance engineering,
there's lots of tools out there.
So these are just a handful.
You can use things like
strace, iostat, eBPF, asprof.
These are all tools that
can help you go very deep
into parts of your program.
And this becomes a problem
'cause now you're taking meandering paths.
It's no longer this nice concise
loop, straight line path.
You may have to look really
deep, take a couple false turns,
take a couple dead ends
before you find your tuning opportunities
and then come back to remeasure
what you've done, see if it's helped.
This has turns out been
somewhat of a problem
even on my team
where we try to use things like intuition
to know what tools to use
and we said let's take a
step back and figure out,
and this is the things we
wanna share with you from AWS.
We said, let's take a step back
'cause we're doing these
performance engineering problems
and we're not getting as
far and as fast as we want.
And we found our intuition
is actually something
that gets in our way.
Intuition can be misleading.
Doing these deaf first searches
can be very inefficient,
especially if you pick
the wrong path first
before you come back out
and say, oops, that didn't do anything,
let's go somewhere else.
And it's simply if we said
let's try going wide before we go deep.
And that's just what it sounds like.
Breadth first search,
prioritize our opportunities
by looking at the full system first.
And when I say full system,
things that me may not even think about
when it first comes to
finding performance,
some people will say, well it's my code,
I should know what to go fix in my code,
but maybe you need to look
at something more system wide
that's not even related to your code.
And that's where we found
that sometimes big gains
hide in plain sight.
We had another customer that said
we need to optimize the
compression library.
It's absolutely the compression library.
And that's where intuition
was telling us to go.
And we took the step back and said,
let's look at the whole system first.
And it turned out compression
wasn't even the bottleneck,
it was just the machine
was running out of memory
and then swapping to disk.
We fixed that opportunity
and then the performance lifted
up by 50% and we were done.
So putting that into graph form,
we say, let's define our measurement,
look at all of our signals,
get the system wide understanding,
get our tuning candidates
and then we'd finally go deep
after we pick the ones that
seem the most profitable
to go look at.
And it's all well and
good to talk about it,
but we decided,
or we should say, we wanna
share with you a tool
that we've developed
that helps take away the,
I have to remember 15
different tools to go use
to get my wide view before I go deep.
And we started developing this
tool and now it's on GitHub
in version 1.0 as of
last week, called APerf.
And it's a wide and deep focus tool,
it's not meant to go deep in
just code performance tuning.
It's meant to look at
everything very, very wide
before we go deep.
And Toby can share a couple anecdotes
as how he's used it in his role.
- [Toby] Yeah, so as I say,
I don't know if mine's still on.
As I say, you know,
oftentimes customers call us,
"We're in an account,
"we have some problem
we have to deal with."
The beautiful thing about Aperf,
how many people have heard
of APerf before today?
No.
Okay, one.
Okay, the performance engineer has.
Great.
So that's good.
But the beautiful thing
about it is that it lets us,
you know, oftentimes if I have
a problem that I can't solve
and I need to bring it
to Geoff and his team,
we need some kind of
common set of language,
some kind of common
data to do that, right?
APerf is that tool.
It lets us,
we ask a customer if they're
having a particular problem,
go deploy it, record
some sample of some run,
let us know what's
happening, send it to us.
It packages up a nice tar ball
with all the reports in it
and we could then visualize it,
we could send it downstream
if we're stumped.
So it's a nice thing for
just making a shared reality
for all parties.
- [Geoff] Okay.
So before we go any further,
I wanna say it's not the only tool,
it's a tool for your toolbox.
It's a good wide and deep tool.
As I said, there's plenty
of other tools out there
that go much deeper.
I could talk forever about
some of those deeper tools
if you catch me after.
But APerf, as I said, we
wanna measure hundreds
of system wide statistics,
just things from very high
level CPU utilization,
memory utilization,
all the way down to the
deep low level metrics
that tell you how the
CPU itself is performing.
And all of these signals
can be taken together
to try and find those opportunities.
It's meant to be simple to use.
It's a self-contained binary.
You put it on the system
under test, it's a point tool.
You don't have to onboard a huge service
or infrastructure to get it going.
You can use a test box, put
it on there, take a recording,
pull the recording off,
and then it generates a
static set of webpages,
which will show as we
get into the code portion
of this talk.
And it's very low overhead.
We've measured it, it has
less than 5% of one CPU
when everything is turned on,
which we find to be an
acceptable trade off
to get the hundreds of
statistics we want to measure.
- [Toby] And how about deployment?
- [Geoff] Deployment can be,
you can just SCP it onto your VM,
onto your bare metal lab
machine or it has the ability
to be packaged up in a container,
and we can put it into
something like a Kubernetes pod
to measure a Kubernetes node
in a privileged container,
which we know is a fairly common use case
for deploying web services.
And that's a new capability
we've been working on
in the last month or so,
and we'll show that here today as well.
Okay, I'm gonna hand it back to Toby,
get on my laptop to get
things set for the demos
and he'll explain what we're
gonna talk about first.
- [Toby] Cool, thank you.
So as we mentioned, Groovy
is gonna be the first demo,
not because we love
Groovy or anything else,
but because it has some of
the stuff we're talking about.
Anybody heard of aspect
oriented programming?
Okay, AOP, it's been around forever.
It's basically the idea that you've got
some cross-cutting concern,
you wanna apply it to a
bunch of different methods.
Maybe we want to do logging
or we want to do whatever the case may be.
You could define that as an aspect
and you could apply that
aspect in multiple places.
Beautiful for maintainability, right?
For testability, for
readability, all of those things.
Not without costs.
Just like everything in engineering,
there is always a trade off.
And so really the goal, one
of the goals of this talk
is to help you understand
what those costs are
so you know where to
make those trade offs.
Yeah, so again, the example
is not terribly contrived.
It's fairly full featured, we think.
Here's the setup, the topology
of it's a simple cluster.
We've got three node groups,
one dedicated to our load generator,
and we're using wrk2,
which is just a nice load generator,
gives you nice tail latency numbers,
and tells you request per
second, and all that stuff.
An M7g is using a few different flavors,
one for an unoptimized version
and then another one
will just restart the pod
with some optimizations, and
see what effects we have.
And then we have an M8g
which is also a potential option for you
if you're trying to get
performance outta the system.
You'd always make the
hardware bigger, right?
You could always make it faster
by potentially throwing
more hardware at it.
So we walk through all those scenarios
and kind of do a price
performance analysis.
We kind of verbally give that to you,
but we have some numbers we can
give you at the end of that.
And with that I'll let Geoff switch over
and we'll get to the demo.
- [Geoff] Okay, so I'm
gonna be showing everything
in my VS Code window.
So can everyone read this
better in the back row?
Do I need to go a little bigger?
- [Toby] Back row guys, everybody's good?
Okay.
- [Geoff] So-so.
Let me know if I need
to go one option bigger.
It's already a little cramped but,
so I'm just gonna show really quick.
This is the container we're
building our Groovy app into.
It's based on Amazon Linux 2023.
We put Corretto 21 on
there for our Java engine
and then we installed our Groovy app
by building it with Gradle,
and then we transfer it onto a server
or a container that's using
Tomcat for our web server.
And we just throw this on here
and we use some very,
very basic CatalinAOPtions
for the JVM, some 8gigabytes of Heap,
G1GC, very basic stuff.
And now we're gonna go take a look
at the Groovy code itself.
So what we did here is we
just started building up
a very simple web application.
As Toby said, it's not
completely contrived
but it's meant to show examples,
not so much be a full
fledged enterprise service,
but we've seen this help
with other customers
running full fledged services.
So it's a relatively good example.
And what you might do in a
JVM type language like Groovy
is you're gonna start defining endpoints
like the hello endpoint,
the process endpoint
with some argument to it.
And as we go along,
we're gonna say we want to do
some things in our endpoints,
but we primarily want to curve
a separation of concerns.
We want our business service
logic and its own package.
We want to call that from our endpoint
or endpoint just handles
HTTP request incoming
and responding to them.
But as you might build up an application,
and if we go through here,
we can see we have other
endpoints like a message endpoint,
a setup endpoint for authorizing users,
a health check endpoint
'cause we're in Kubernetes.
And also, you know, we wanna
be able to pull metrics,
say our,
another health check in
the Kubernetes cluster
wants to pull some metrics to keep an eye
on the health of the deployment.
But as we go, we might say,
well we really want to take a look
at all the people accessing our systems.
We wanna log every client IP
to get security auditing going.
We want to check that we have
everything is authorized,
and the way we're applying these aspects
that we can look in here,
aspects are in the aspects directory,
and all the code for doing authorization
and stuff is in here.
And we can do that either as annotations
or if we say we want metrics
to apply to everything,
we can do that with spring
boot that we built upon,
with cut point filters.
So we're really taking
and leveraging the
aspect-oriented programming
to have everything, all
our concerns separated,
crosscutting code can be applied
to all the endpoints we want,
whether it's explicitly with annotations
or using the cut point filters
to apply it more broadly.
And this builds up a nice web application
that's very clean code.
And the thing that we will start noticing
is that we want to keep the
performance at a breaking SLA,
or breaking SLO, service level objective.
- [Toby] Everybody familiar with SLOs?
With service level objectives?
This is something I hear customers,
that we don't really do
either a good job of conveying
or it's just not out in
the wild for consumption.
SLO, think of it as what you need
for your business to operate, right?
What is it,
it's kinda like an SLA but
it's also, it's more about,
it's from the business perspective
versus the end user perspective.
So what do you want to run, you know,
from your business perspective?
How quickly do you want to run it?
Maybe a P99 of 100 milliseconds
with throughput of 5K
or something like that, right?
You pick that
and then that's what really is kind of,
sets the anchor for your performance.
When you're making changes,
you know if you're going
up or down from that SLO
or staying within it.
If you're outside your SLO,
you're breaching your own
kind of contract, right?
So that's really the
kind of what underpins
a lot of the work that we're doing here.
- [Geoff] Yeah, and the SLO should be
ideally something you
set at business time,
not necessarily a comparison
to something you've done
before, but in this case,
our SLO is, we wanna stay
under P99 of 100 milliseconds.
And we found the braking latency,
if we went past 4,000 requests per second,
which is what our work load
generator was giving us,
is we got to about 50 milliseconds,
but then if we went any further,
we went well past 100 milliseconds,
past 4,000 RPS.
- [Toby] And you've probably
seen that curve before, right?
The breaking latency curve,
it's going up, I'm at 2000,
I'm at 3000, I'm at 4,000, I'm at 5,000.
It starts to plateau and then diminishes.
That knee of the curve
is the breaking latency.
We're staying right at that latency.
- [Geoff] So we're gonna say
for the sake of this code talk,
we're gonna say this isn't fast enough.
We want to go faster, we
want to get above 5,000,
we want to get maybe up to 10,000,
more than double the performance.
And how are we go about doing that?
So the first thing you might say is,
well we can maybe optimize the code,
but there's, if you
look through, you know,
because this is an
example for a code talk,
there's not a whole lot here,
there's not a lot of logic,
you know, metrics aspects
is inserting something
into a concurrent hash map.
Our business logic isn't
terribly complex right now,
but we're still not able to
push all that much throughput
for 100 milliseconds at P99.
So we're gonna, we've already
gathered an APerf report
that we'll go into next.
As we're looking at that APerf report,
I'm going to kick off an optimized run
that we will come back to in
about three or four minutes.
And if you notice here,
we're gonna patch our pod
and I'm gonna put
in a bunch of different JavAOPtimizations,
and these optimizations,
we'll talk about in turn
as to why we're doing that,
and why we would do something
using the signals we got from APerf.
- [Toby] And I'll just add.
So we're doing a lot of
this through a script.
So we've done it just to
make our lives easier.
If anybody's interested in
what that script's doing
come up afterwards,
we're happy to show you.
It's basically just deploying
the pod, starting the run,
recording, and stopping,
making sure that everything's
kind of got good timing
and everything.
- [Geoff] Okay, so we already
gathered the APerf report
for the base program
and this is on an
M7g.xlarge with four CPUs.
And when you open up an APerf
report from the index.HTML,
it's this type of webpage.
- [Toby] Before we continue,
sorry to interrupt you Geoff.
This is an unplanned interruption.
How many have heard of
or are using Graviton?
So like a show of hands
of who's heard of it
and knows what it is.
Okay, so probably about
six, 70% of the room.
How many are using it?
Okay, great.
For those who aren't, come to,
I want to talk to you
afterwards and find out why.
But okay, you can continue.
- [Geoff] Okay, and another disclaimer
is that everything we talk here,
most of it will apply to
X86-based instances as well.
A lot of things that we
talk about for Graviton
aren't just special to Graviton,
but we're using Graviton because you know,
I know a lot about how
to make it run faster
so it seemed a logical choice.
So APerf, as you can see
here, has a homepage.
It just tells you some
very basic statistics
about the recording that you did.
Things like check that your AMI ID
is what you thought it was,
check your instance type
check the kernel version is at the version
that you expected to measure.
These are all things that are
very wide, seem very simple,
but I've personally run into cases
where we've had people tell us like,
"Well we ran the comparison
on a 24xlarge system
and we're comparing against an 8xlarge,
and the 8xlarge is slower.
And I'm like, well okay
that seems expected
but you know let's,
these types of things pop up
and sometimes it's good to
have that right in your face
as the first thing.
And then along the left hand side
we have a bunch of different statistics.
As I said we collect hundreds
of different statistics
and we've grouped them into logical units
like CPU utilization,
all the different CPU utilizations
and we can click on that,
and we get aggregate CPU utilization
with time series along the X axis
and utilization along the Y.
And we can see we're pushing
around 60, 75% CPU utilization
for this application.
We're really riding along the top edge
of how much we can get out of this pod
because we told it, you
only get to use three CPUs
and it's a four CPU node.
Nothing here looks out of the ordinary.
And this is where the wide part comes in,
and we wanna start looking
at different things.
You know, maybe we check
our memory utilization,
is it going up and down?
Is it doing something odd?
And we see, no, we're
staying pretty constant.
Our heap is doing what we expect.
There's a lot of other things in here.
I encourage everyone to go out
and take APerf for a quick spin
and see if it's measuring things
that you might not already be measuring
or not already thinking about.
So we get things like more
detailed virtual memory stats,
interrupts, disk stats, kernel configs,
Sysctl kernel config,
where you can go and tune,
to fine tune things like
the TCP networking stack
or your scheduler, if it's
not behaving like you expect.
And then we also get code
profiles like flame graphs,
standard system flame graphs from Perf.
We're running a Java application
so it doesn't look like much here
but we also have the ability to interface
with async-profiler
and we're able to do CPU
utilization profiling.
- [Toby] Have folks seen
flame graphs before?
Okay, so for those who don't know,
flame graph, it really is
showing you a population
of function calls along the X axis
and stacked depth along the Y.
So if you see a wider bar,
that's not necessarily
how much time was spent
in that function,
it's how many times that
function was called.
So it's just a pure, pure
alphabetic, numerical,
or sorry, alphabetic number.
So a population of function
calls would determine width
along with stack depth.
- [Geoff] Yep.
So it gives you a
proportion of how much time
each function is run.
Not necessarily telling you the, you know,
like the order is only applicable
when you're going up and
down the stack depth.
And if you're going from left to right,
there's no information there.
You only have to look at
the widths of the bars.
And async-profiler is used
here to gather these plots.
There's a little legend here,
for those that are curious,
you know, bright green is JIT compiled,
so that means the Java JIT
has actually compiled it
into native code.
Light cyan is inlined,
and dark blue is things that
you're matching against.
But the first thing we
wanna notice here is
in this flame graph, if I was gonna say
I wanna optimize my AOP code,
I wanna make the code faster
is that this stack trace
has lots of functions
that I personally don't
ever remember writing.
I don't remember writing
an internal do filter
or invoke exact_MT@20.
And these are all of the things
that implements the aspects
in the object oriented
programming in this JVM language
that we wrote this in.
And it goes on for
almost seemingly forever.
It's over 100 stack frames deep.
And if I tried to look for code
with this little magnifying
glass AOP heavy code,
it's found some, but we have to go
and we find a handful of things
that are things that we wrote.
So there's really not much we
can do to optimize this code,
if we just wanted to go
in and hack on our code.
We probably need to go
look at another signal,
another opportunity.
And one of those opportunities might be,
let's go look at why the
CPU is not performing
as fast as we think it should be.
And before I go deeper into
the PMU view of things,
let's just give,
how many people here are micro architects
that have looked at how a CPU works?
Any, it's Intel?
One person, okay,
I'm gonna have to talk to you after this.
- [Julio] I work in our,
we used to be on the
same team many years ago.
- [Geoff] Oh Julio.
Okay, now I recognize
the voice. (chuckling)
Definitely talk to you.
- [Julio] Yeah, I look
very different now, I think.
- [Geoff] No, it's the
lights in my eyes, man.
Okay.
All right, let's talk
about how a CPU works
because I'm gonna go
into lots of CPU metrics,
well, not lots but quite a few.
So for those that don't know,
a CPU is literally the
simplest loop state machine
you've ever heard of.
It gets instructions, we do
some math, we go back to one.
And this is the abstraction
that we all kind of depend on
and it goes around this loop
billions of times a second
for any modern CPU.
A Graviton CPU is almost three gigahertz,
3 billion instructions per second.
Some of the high end desktops
can get almost to 6 billion instructions,
6 billion cycles a second.
But it's really just getting instructions
and executing them,
it's just doing some math.
But to go a little bit further
to look at what APerf can tell you
is we want to look at a
little bit more detail.
A modern CPU because it's trying
to get as much performance
as possible as two halves.
We'll talk about a front
half and a back half.
The front half gets
instructions from memory
and feeds it into a queue
that the back half executes.
This is almost like a microservice
where you have separations
of concerns again,
where one half is doing some
work pushing it to a queue
and the back half is doing some more.
But the front half can't
wait for the back half
to tell it if it's going down
the right path in your loops
or in your If conditionals.
So it's constantly predicting
where to go next from
the previous history.
So if your loop is doing 1,000 iterations,
this front half will try to predict like,
I saw this loop previously,
I'm gonna do 1,000 iterations of this loop
and feed it to the back end,
and hopefully that's correct.
And the back end will then tell it
whether or not those were correct.
And every time you're wrong
or the front-end got
the wrong instructions,
you basically have to flush the
entire thing and start over.
And that's a very painful, painful thing
to have in your code.
You want these two halves
to operate at full speed at all times
and then you'll get the
maximum performance.
And so let's go back to the demo.
Alright, so the very first thing
we're gonna look at is just
what's the throughput of our CPU?
And this is this IPC metric,
which is, APerf now has some annotations,
you can click on things to get some help.
This is instructions per cycle.
Instructions per cycle is just
how fast the CPU is processing
and you really want to have
something greater than one.
And if we look at the average
here, it's actually under one.
So we're spending a lot of
time doing not a lot of work.
We want to drive this as
high as possible actually,
for most of our code.
Modern CPUs can get
anywhere upwards of eight
to 12 instructions per
cycle through their pipeline
if you get everything aligned.
It's very hard to do this,
but I'm just saying that
CPUs have this capability,
they're really fast.
So we want to go a little bit further.
And APerf puts our PMU stats
in ways that we can understand
just like we had in that slide.
So we can look at front-end stuff first
and we can see that front-ends is in
stalls per 1,000 instruction,
or a 1,000 cycles.
So anything above zero here
means that things are stalling
and not doing any work,
and we're at almost 60% of the timer,
600 cycles out of 1,000.
The front-end can't actually
feed anything into the backend.
So we really should
probably look at here first,
but since we said let's go wide than deep,
let's see if our backend
is actually worse.
It's not.
The backend's actually
processing things pretty fast.
It's at two, it's only stalling
200 times out of 1,000.
So we can put that to the side
and say our opportunity's
really on the front-end.
So what are things that
we can can look at there?
Some things are branch misses.
How many times we're wrong in predicting
the previous behavior as future behavior?
And this is another thing we want to go
and make as close to zero as possible.
Something like 10 per 1,000
is actually not great.
It's meaning the CPU is stalling
and flushing things pretty often.
The same thing is the instruction memory
we're fetching from being well utilized.
Well, there's caches along
the CPU micro architecture
before you get to main memory
and you wanna be able to
put all your instructions
in the closest memory is possible.
So it's really fast and easy to fetch.
And in this case we're also
not doing a very good job here.
We're missing outta that cash a lot,
60 times out of every 1,000 instructions.
And we can see the same thing
of translating virtual addresses,
physical addresses is
also fairly high at four.
So all of these stats I'm going through,
you wanna drive as close
to zero as possible.
So I want to go back
to those JVM ops that,
options that we put in,
and we'll talk about the actual
results from that script.
But the things that we did were,
we said everything in the
front-end we want to...
So things you wanna do
to make things front-end-bound happier
is you want to put things close together,
squeeze the instructions as
close together as possible
and you want to,
and those things help you put
things in closer memories.
It helps the branch predictor
track all the history
because it is also a cache.
And if things are spread out
too far, it'll start missing.
And we also want to put things
in contiguous parts and memory as well.
So we put take pressure off the things
that do the translation.
And these are all options
that we actually put into
our Java application.
We said, I wanna turn
off tiered compilation,
which mean, tiered compilation
is a way for the JVM
to get faster startup times.
It compiles methods twice.
Once in a very simple assembly code
and then after it sees
it, run a couple times,
and it actually does a full optimization.
So it actually keeps two copies around
and that takes up space
and pollutes your caches.
But we can turn that off
if we're not worried about startup time.
Some people might be, so
maybe you wanna keep this on,
it's a thing to experiment with.
Same thing with reserved code cache size
and initial code cache size.
The default is 256 megabytes
and the JVM, in this
case, is not very smart
about where it places methods.
It'll just find a gap and
put the methods there.
But if you constrict
the space it can be in,
it'll actually start packing
methods better for you.
And then finally, we
UseTransparentHugePages,
and this is a way to force the machine
or force the JVM
to put things in contiguous
memory addresses.
So you have to use less entries
to translate virtual, physical memory.
And all these options were just
options on the command line.
We didn't have to change code,
we only had to redeploy our pod.
And the final results of that is we got,
now we got almost 20% more throughput
at 4,750 requests per second.
And our P99 is still under
that 100 milliseconds.
So that's actually pretty good.
Pretty cheap tunings for a 20%,
almost 20% return on that.
And we can take a look at the report.
Did any of the things I just talked about
making the front-end better actually work?
- [Toby] And real quick, I'll
just point out, you know,
we're talking a lot about
Java and Groovy right now
and the tunings that
you could do in the JVM.
There's corollary tunings
for basically all languages
and all platforms, right?
So we do have some of
this stuff documented.
We'll touch on that in a second,
but just pointing out, not to,
I don't want to go too
far down the Groovy thing
and lose people,
but letting you know that
APerf is gonna be the thing
that surfaces those signals.
And if you do get those signals,
how do you fix 'em, right?
Like that's what we're really
trying to teach you here.
- [Geoff] Yeah.
Yeah, we're trying to
focus on, use the data,
use all the data to try to
guide where your, you know,
best return on investment
and optimization can be.
And so here's a comparison report.
So this is another feature that APerf has
that we find very useful,
is you can put two reports side by side.
So now we can go and do
a compare and contrast,
an A/B comparison.
- [Toby] So this is super interesting,
but what happens if we have two different
micro architectures in our APerf.
So if we've got say an M7g on the left
and M6i on the right?
- [Geoff] So the report
does the exact same thing
and we'll put 'em side by side.
And as much as possible,
the metrics that we collect
will be named the same
and be comparable between each other.
So the PMU events will be named the same
and they'll map to the same basic ideas.
So cache misses are still cache misses,
instructions per cycle is
still instructions per cycle.
So you can look at them
and compare one to one.
- [Toby] So that's pretty huge,
if you've ever done any
kind of performance stuff,
understanding the different, you know,
the different nuances between
say Intel, and AMD, and our
is a big thing that we've
already done for you.
So that's good.
- [Geoff] Yep, okay.
So let's jump straight to the PMU things
and so we can show some
other features here.
So we had not only the
summary in the original report
of this time series thing,
if we're not wanting to squint too hard,
is this line actually 10%
higher than the other line?
We've now put a
summarization on the reports
under comparison and we can see-
- [Toby] Pretty small.
- [Geoff] That's pretty small
but I'll blow it up just a little bit.
We can see that instructions per cycle
did get 12% better on average.
So we did do what we said we could do.
We actually improved the
performance of the CPU
by about 13%, even though
the score went up by 17%.
Stall front-ends actually
went down by about 6%.
It may not seem big,
but every time you can
reduce front-end stalls,
they're far more expensive
than anything on the backend.
'Cause the front-end works
pretty much in order.
It has to get one set of instructions
before it can get the next from memory.
But the backend can do things
way out of order and in parallel.
And if we look at stall backends,
this is kind of the interesting
thing you might notice
is that when you remove one bottleneck
you start pushing on another,
and if you removed all
the stall front-ends,
you'd actually see this would blow up
to be a huge difference in
the negative, in the red,
because now you've moved the bottleneck
from one part of the CPU,
in this case, to another,
but as we talked about, this
can happen in code as well.
Other things that happened
is branch miss predictions
went down by 20%.
So that's good.
We're doing exactly
what we said we would do
and all the things that
we thought would happen
because we constricted the code cache,
we reduced the number of
times we recompile methods.
And I'll show you just a
second when we put things
in contiguous memory, things get faster.
So instructions got packed tighter.
So we're missing less in
the instruction L1 cache
and then we put things
in contiguous memory,
and we got a big jump
in the amount of times
we miss in the cache that
translates from virtual addresses
to physical addresses.
So the core doesn't always have to fault
and go look through a page table,
it doesn't take page faults all the time.
It actually tries to
cache those translations.
And we can see this went down by 60%.
So a big, big decrease.
But if 20 percent's not
enough, what can we do then?
We can continue down this path of,
well, let's get the hardware
just to execute our code
faster and we can go to M8g.
And we've already run
this in the background.
M8g is getting 7,000 requests
per second for the same code
with the same optimizations,
and we're actually running
at a little bit better
of a P99 latency,
but again, if we push past
7,000, it blows up pretty quick.
So we're already at our
breaking latency here.
7,000, okay, we got 60
or 70% more performance,
10% higher cost,
it's a 60% price performance benefit
from going from 7g to 8g.
That's actually a pretty big win.
And so far we haven't
actually touched any code,
if you've noticed.
If we open that report,
I'll go through that really quick.
And this is comparing back to the same one
that we just looked at
the optimized code path
against an optimized code path in 8g,
and if we increase that
one, we get 38% more IPC.
- [Toby] Just to jump in
here, this is a function
of the processor getting better, right?
Like so the processor got more efficient
and was able to give
us these gains, right?
- [Geoff] Yeah.
- [Toby] And so you'd see that,
year over year probably, or gen over gen
on not only Graviton but
basically any processor,
that everybody's endeavoring to do
this kind of stuff, right?
- [Geoff] Everyone's trying
to get the processor faster
so you get those free upgrades.
And Graviton is no different.
So every generation we've
been trying to shoot
for 20 to 25%,
Intel and AMD try to do the same,
if we've got plenty of different levers
to make things faster.
But you can see even in APerf
that this is what's happening.
The cores are getting faster
going from seventh gen to eighth gen,
and we're getting a lot of performance
for a fairly small bump in price.
If that's a trade off
you're willing to make.
As we can see, backend stalls
actually got higher again
because we've moved the bottleneck
from front-end to backend,
and branch misses went down by almost 50%.
So everything got better.
But we could say, now I
don't wanna move to 8g,
what can we do then?
- [Toby] Or like maybe
there's some constraint,
maybe we haven't dropped 8g in the region
that you have to run in or
something like that, right?
So it's a real problem
that we've heard customers talk about.
- [Geoff] Okay.
So at that point what's one of the answers
and really the, as we said,
everything has a cost.
And aspect-oriented programming
or leveraging object-oriented
programming interfaces,
abstract classes, lots of derived classes,
all of these have costs.
And a lot of the times the
cost is hidden in extra code
to make all of these nice
software abstractions
and constructs work in
that, they run extra code.
And if we are really set
on, we need to use 7g,
then we have to go and
actually change the code.
In this case we went the extreme version,
we removed all of the aspects,
except for the very handful
of ones we absolutely need,
like using the aspects to turn
these into HTTP endpoints.
And we started inlining
a lot of the aspects
that we showed earlier,
like tracking authorization
stats is now in-lined,
logging is now in-lined.
And if we go into here, we can also see,
oh, this is my, this is
the hello or the, yeah.
The other things in here
is we also inline metrics,
we also inlined rate limiting.
So a lot of things we've taken away,
we've made the trade off now is,
we're gonna make the
code less maintainable.
And maybe this is not a
trade off you wanna make,
but if we did, the question now becomes,
well did this do anything?
Did we spend a lot of effort
and a lot of tech, you know,
potentially tech debt to get
a small mean, modest gain?
And in this case, the answer for that was-
- [Toby] Just to jump in here again,
like, I hope I don't see a review
or somebody in a survey that says,
"Geoff and Toby told us
"not to use object-oriented programming."
Like that's not the goal, right?
The goal is to show that there
is a cost to all this stuff.
It's not for free,
although in your organization
or whatever else,
you may value maintainability
and readability more than performance,
and that is perfectly fine.
But that's your decision to make.
- [Geoff] Yep.
And the point is that
you can use all the data
to try to come to these trade offs.
You're seeing the CPU going slow,
you have flame graphs
that are two, 300, 400 stack frames deep,
that's all telling you that the code
might have gotten too complex
or the things you're using are
adding lots of extra overhead
that wasn't immediately obvious,
just by looking at the
code that you wrote.
And if we wind things back
and take away some of these aspects,
we actually get a pretty
large healthy return
for our application.
We're up to 11,000 requests per second,
and still under our SLO
of 100 milliseconds,
we're at 28 and-
- [Toby] And that's on 7g, right?
- [Geoff] That's on 7g.
So 7g to 7g, we can
increase the performance
by almost 3X, just by
rearranging parts of our code.
We still have the same functionality
but how it's implemented, compiled,
and then run has changed.
And we can go and take
a look at the report
and these are all scripts,
just so I can open these up fast.
And we will just go straight
to the Java heat maps.
We can put these also side by side,
and the thing to notice here
is AOP optimizes on the left.
So that's the same code
with all of our aspects.
And then if we run the
clean version on the right,
one thing we noticed is the aspects,
we still have these very,
very deep flame graphs
that are lots and lots of
calls that we have to make
just to make the code work.
And if we start backing those out,
I don't have to scroll down nearly as much
to get to the end of the code.
So really what we did here
is instead of, you know,
I didn't go and make
redo concurrent hash map,
I didn't optimize anything with assembly,
all we did was take away the overheads
that we saw from the
signals we got from APerf,
which was, we're running a
lot of code we didn't expect,
can I take away some of that
code, run less instructions?
And that leads to some pretty
sizable performance gains.
It's not always about,
I came up with a clever new algorithm.
It may just be things like this
that are just hiding in plain sight.
And so that's the Groovy demo.
We do have the Getting Started Guide
for all of these
optimizations we talked about.
- [Toby] Yeah, so that
was the thing I wanted to,
sorry, if I blinded somebody
with the laser there.
That's one thing we wanna talk about.
So there is a Getting
Started Guide, that's the,
it's a Graviton Getting Started Guide,
don't the name fool you.
All the stuff that we suggested in there
is applicable across architecture.
So it's not just a Graviton thing
and it's all for a bunch
of different languages
in there too.
So it's not just gonna be Java
or JVM based languages
that you'll see in C++
and some other stuff in there
too, if you're interested.
Cool.
Any questions on the Groovy stuff?
Any comments, any?
I have stickers I can give away.
Yeah.
- [Audience Member] That paper tool
is not specific to Graviton.
- [Toby] That's correct.
You could run it on on Intel,
AMD, whatever you want.
Okay, so next demo,
and we're coming up on 15 minutes
so we're gonna probably buzz
through this fairly quickly.
We have MongoDB.
The whole goal of this was to show you
that APerf is going to surface signals,
not just of your own code,
but of other things too, right?
It's an ambient collector,
it just sits on the box
and it just collects all this stuff,
and surfaces 'em to you
and gives you nice visuals.
So what if one of those things
that we needed to do was Mongo?
If we had Mongo and it was running poorly,
is there any way, without rewriting Mongo,
is there any way to kind of figure out
why it is running poorly?
So this is our next setup here.
Again, the topology of
this is very, very simple.
Same three node groups.
First one being our load generator,
where we're running YCSB
to kind of load this up.
Another one running two different types.
This is actually, there's a typo in this.
It's an M7g and an M8g,
that is not the case.
We have an M7g and an M7gd.
Does anybody know what the
D on the end of the G is?
It's attached NVME.
So no surprise
which one's gonna probably
run faster here, right?
So we've got EBS back storage
and NVME storage for the gd.
So the two node groups in
M7g xlarge, M7gd xlarge,
both running Mongo.
Again, that little A is indicating
that we have an APerf pod
running on there alongside it,
after we start it up and load it up.
So I'll let Geoff do his thing and we'll-
- [Geoff] Okay.
- [Toby] Look at that.
- [Geoff] Okay, so because
this is an application
that we didn't write,
we're not gonna show any code of Mongo.
We're just gonna say we deployed
a pod with this pod spec
where we took Mongo 8.0 and said,
"Okay, we wanna run
Mongo 8.0 on three cores
and we want to get, you know,
say 6,000 requests per
second on Mongo 8.0,
and we're gonna attach some storage to it.
And we just attach 128
gigabytes of storage
and we use a volume claim,
persistent volume claim on gp2
and we think this should be good enough.
And if we run YCSB against
it, just to load test
and see if we're correct.
We come out with a score of
only 4,000 requests per second.
And so this is a case where,
well, what can we do to make this faster?
And we're not gonna optimize code.
The point of this talk is
to show you can optimize
by optimizing EC2,
how do you do it with all of EC2,
all the instance types available?
And so again, we went and recorded APerf,
what will APerf show us?
So we go and start looking
at all the signals first
before we just dive in and say,
"Well, maybe I shouldn't use Mongo."
That is an option, "But
can I make Mongo go faster?
"'Cause I really want to use Mongo
"for some features it has."
So we'll open up the EBS report.
Again, now we should be very familiar
with the APerf start page.
We made sure we were running on M7g
and we don't have to go very
far before we see a problem.
We see that our CPU utilization
total is pegged at 100%
or very close to 100%.
And along the legend we are looking for,
if we look for user and
system, it's way down here,
it's hardly using any like
active user code at all.
And because we're using EBS,
we're actually sitting a lot of times
just waiting for the disk we're in IO wait
most of the time, 65, 80% of the time.
IO wait is just a signal telling you that,
"Hey, I have threads ready to run.
"They could do something if my
disk came back fast enough."
And so in this case, we're
just looking at, you know,
we're disk- bound.
I don't have to change the code.
Maybe if I just throw in
something with faster storage,
we can do better.
And we have a little thing-
- [Toby] This is where we have
to say, what are the costs?
- [Geoff] Okay, yeah, here we go.
So this is another thing
we're thinking about,
with performance engineering,
we look at it holistically
with all our data,
it's what are the costs to access data?
This graph is just all the
various things you can access
on the system that,
some form of memory or
storage from a CPU register
all the way up to S3.
And along the Y axis is latency
and nanoseconds on a log scale.
So as we go, we're increasing
the amount of time it takes
by 10X, it's a log 10 scale
and it's not even a linear chart.
It's actually more than linear.
So it's more than exponential
as we get out to disk where we're taking
tens of thousands of nanoseconds,
hundreds of thousands.
And if you're using S3 as your storage,
it's tens of millions to hundreds
of millions of nanoseconds
to just gather some data
to use for your compute.
And in the CPU terms, that's an eternity.
If we put this into human time,
this chart is just that same
graph but in a table form.
The CPU times are in the actual time,
but if we scaled it to,
you're doing the math,
you're the math engine,
and you can do a math
problem once a second.
If we're going out to
local EBS or remote EBS,
'cause EBS is its own
distributed storage system
that's spread across an entire region.
If you have to get a piece of data
before you can complete your calculation,
it could take anywhere from
20 of your days or my days,
to half a year of sitting there
waiting for someone to
run and get you the paper
and give it to you.
And that's where we say,
well, maybe we should try
something like local SSD, the gd,
it would only take it one day.
That's a order of magnitude faster.
So we'll go back and we'll
see if that's actually true.
If the data that we collected with APerf
is actually going to
give us some advantages.
If we went to say the 7gd
and we ran this in the background
while we've been talking.
And if we run YCSB with 7gd,
we see a 3X performance increase,
we're up to 12,000 requests per second.
And it does exactly, if I
opened up the APerf report,
you'll see exactly that IO
wait goes down to almost zero
and our CPU time is now
the dominant factor.
We're actually computing
stuff on our document database
instead of just waiting for
the disk to get back to us.
And so that ends the code demo.
- [Toby] Okay.
- [Geoff] Yep.
- [Toby] Cool, so back to the PowerPoint.
So takeaways?
- [Geoff] Yep.
So takeaways here are just, you know,
performance engineering is
not just about hacking up
great new algorithms and
writing in low level languages,
assembly, or C,
but it's about finding
opportunities wherever they are.
So it may not even be code,
it may just be opportunities
of optimizing the EC2 instances
and their setup that you use.
And we did that plenty during this demo
where we weren't hacking
on code so much as we were,
"Let's try the 8g or 7gd instead of 7g.
And as we said, those
opportunities could be anywhere.
They're not necessarily
always in the algorithm,
they could be how you set up
the networking on your devices,
the instance families that you choose,
the sizes that you choose,
cores and memory ratios.
And so that's where we've
found a lot of great takeaways
to share with you, which is using APerf
or other tools to get that whole view
before you go and start hacking
away to make things faster.
- [Toby] Yeah, part of it is understanding
what your system wants more of, right?
How do you identify that?
And then once you've identified it,
then you can make the right decision,
whether that's new instance,
whether that's faster disks,
or whatever, right?
So that's it.
We've got seven minutes
left or we let you go early,
if you've got questions,
we're happy to answer 'em,
but if not, please fill out a survey,
tell us you loved it,
hated it, or whatever,
so we can get better next time.
But I do have stickers.
I have-